Speaker 1: 2024. Republican presidential candidate
Chris Christie did a CNN town hall last night and
he again proved he is really the only serious
Republican presidential candidate. I tell you
this with no fear or hesitation, because it
appears as though Chris Christie has absolutely
no chance of winning that nomination. He's making
too much sense. He's willing to criticize Donald
Trump. He answers questions when they are asked
of him. I will be the first to say Chris Christie
from 2016 to 2020 seemed to support most of what
Trump did, and for that I think he is horrible.
But if you compare him and contrast him with the
other presidential candidates, including Donald
Trump and Ron DeSantis and others, to Sanctus
the Santos, and now I'm doing it a running for
the 2024 Republican nomination. This is the
only serious person. And he actually could do
a good job in debating Joe Biden because he is
intelligent, he's willing to answer questions.
He's direct. Check out this clip from last night's
town hall. Chris Christie saying they're blaming
everybody but Trump for this indictment. What
about blaming Trump for the things he did?
Speaker 4: And we're in a situation where there
are people in my own party who are blaming DOJ.
How about blame.
Speaker 1: Him? Right.
Speaker 3: He did it. He kept.
Speaker 4: He took documents he wasn't supposed
to take. He kept it when they asked them back for
them. They got a grand jury subpoena. He refused
to comply. They raided his home finally, because
he refused to comply, that all of those things
were brought on himself, as was this resistance.
Speaker 1: This is accurate. What about blaming
the person who did the thing? And if
you look in the comments to these clips,
you see all these MAGA people saying Chris
Christie is a rhino. He's not serious. No
one's taking him seriously. It is true that
because MAGA has taken over the Republican Party,
the one guy who actually makes some sense and is
more in line with the Mitt Romney John McCain type
Republicans seems to have no shot. Now, Steve
Schmidt said last week in our interview that
he actually thinks Chris Christie does have
a shot. We will see. Here is Chris Christie
weighing in on the indictment itself.
Speaker 3: I want to ask you about the
indictments that we've seen. Yesterday.
Speaker 5: Former Attorney General Bill
Barr called the indictment, quote, very damning.
Speaker 3: And he said if even half of it is true,
then he's toast. You're a former
U.S. attorney. Is he right?
Speaker 4: It is a very tight, very detailed
evidence laden indictment. And the context in
there is is awful. I mean, put aside taking the
documents in the first place. But then when you
start getting asked, Anderson in May of 21 nicely
with a letter from the archivist saying, could
you please give it back? And you ignore it, ignore
it, ignore it, Then they come with the grand jury
subpoena. And then according to the indictment,
you tell your lawyers, tell them we don't
have anything, even though you have dozens and
dozens of boxes of material, that's obstruction
of justice if it's true. And so I think the
former attorney general is absolutely right.
Speaker 1: This is an actual proper legal
analysis from a prosecutor who is not so
blinded by Partizanship. And he also has
an incentive to criticize Trump. Obviously,
Chris Christie, again, making the point
at another moment, we blame everybody but
ourselves for our losses. We should blame the fact
that Trump is a loser and he lost everything for
us. An argument I've been making for a while now.
Speaker 4: It makes me feel even more important.
I'm just telling you. I've known him for 22
years. The only thing he understands is force.
The only thing he understands is coming right
at him and making your case. And if these other
candidates don't want to do it, the American
people and Republican primary voters have to
start to understand this. When did. When do we get
to the point? We're always playing our adversaries
for the weakness of our candidates, right? Oh,
it's the Democrats fault. It's Dodge's fault. It's
this person's fault. The media's fault. How bad is
his? He hasn't won a damn thing since 2016. Three
time loser. 2018. We lost the house. 2020. We lost
the White House. We lost the United States Senate
a couple of weeks later in 2021. And in 2022, we
lost two more governorships, another Senate seat,
and barely took the House of Representatives
when Joe Biden had the most incompetent first
two years I've ever seen in my life.
Speaker 1: That I disagree with.
But it's obviously what he has to say.
Speaker 4: Loser. Loser. Loser. Now we're getting
going. It'll be different this time.
Speaker 3: Why?
Speaker 4: Why will it be different this
time? Those arguments need to be made,
and I'm not afraid to make them.
Speaker 1: This is the only guy who's
actually saying this stuff. Why? Why won't Tim
Scott do this? Why won't DeSantis do this? Why?
They are all weak. Other than Chris Christie.
He's polling 1.3%. We'll see where it goes.